donald john trump
our nation's 45th and potentially 47th
president
is in such self-control that he just hit
a hole-in-one while playing a round of
golf
the reason this is a news story well
it's impressive to hit all-in-one
but the reason it's a news story is not
because trump hit a hole in one it's
because of the statement that he issued
trump issues a full press release and
these press releases read kind of like
long tweets ever since he was kicked off
twitter i i want to read it in full if
you'll indulge me i have to read you
this statement by trump in full he says
many people are asking so i'll give it
to you now it is 100 true while playing
with the legendary golfer ernie ells
winner of four majors and approximately
72 other tournaments throughout the
world jean sauers winner of the senior
us open ken duke and mike goods both
excellent tour players i made a hole in
one
it took place at trump international
golf club in west palm beach florida on
the seventh hole which was playing 181
yards into a slight wind
i hit a five iron which sailed
magnificently into a rather strong wind
with approximately five feet of cut
whereupon it bounced twice and then went
italicized clank
into the hole these great tour players
noticed it before i did because their
eyes are slightly better but on that one
hole only their swings weren't anyway
there's a lot of chatter about it quite
exciting and people everywhere seem to
be asking for the facts
sorry i'm sorry
it's too good
playing with that group of wonderful
talented players was a lot of fun the
match was ernie and me with no strokes
against gene mike and ken i won't tell
you who won
because i'm a very modest individual and
you you will then say i was bragging and
i don't like people who brag
watch the video here
and then it's a video of trump's
hole-in-one why do i read that one i
read it because it's incredibly funny
and i miss him so much and i just wish
he were on twitter and all of our lives
would be at least 40 percent funnier
and more filled with humor if trump were
still on twitter but the other reason i
mention it
is because this is a man
in self-control
yes he was a billionaire playboy yes
he's had a colorful life
but beyond some minor indiscretions here
there he really is a man in self-control
he doesn't drink he barely sleeps he's a
workaholic he
shockingly keeps himself in relatively
decent shape for a retired president who
lives on a diet of fast food and diet
coke he actually seems to have a lot of
energy
and he doesn't let his emotions run away
with him when he's
making points even in the heat
of passion
he's always controlled
you've got the
nuclear maniac
uh kim jong-un
north korea calling trump an old
daughter and threatening to blow up
america
and what does trump do does he react in
an emotional way
no he says oh little rocket man i would
never call him short and fat well i hope
he knows i've got a button and mine's
bigger hahaha he's always
he's crafting these jokes in a way
that tells you it's cool he's going to
let it roll off him he's he's
in command the same cannot be said of
joe biden
right now stop what you're doing before
inflation gets worse and text knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s to 9 8 9 8 9 8 to get all
the info you need inflation is at 7
right now okay thanks to joe biden's
insane policies that means that the
paper money in your wallet is losing
value fast
russia's full-on invasion of ukraine
not making things any better actually
worsening the markets decline today an
ounce of gold is worth nineteen hundred
dollars in the year two thousand you
know what it was worth
three hundred dollars what if you had
invested in gold then i've been saying
for years and years now that you can buy
gold from birch gold that it is your
hedge against inflation these are the
guys that i trust well did you know
there's another way to hedge against
inflation
you can buy silver from birch gold
silver and gold silver and gold silver
is also considered real money
historically speaking it's extremely
undervalued right now it's an industrial
metal it's in high demand for everything
from electric cars to solar panels to
everything
demand is only going to rise
protect your savings today text knolls k
w l e s to 98 98 98 to get a free info
kit on buying gold or silver in a tax
sheltered account there's no obligation
to get this info you just you get the
info you text knowles canadawles2989898
get your free info kit now
i'm glad you like that clip now what i
need you to do is ring the bell
subscribe get all the notifications also
if you can head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify wherever you get
your podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]